y la gota es una enfermedad artrítica de
las articulaciones causada por un exceso
de ácido úrico en el cuerpo generalmente
el hígado procesa diversas sustancias en
el cuerpo incluyendo las purinas que son
componentes del material genético
encontrado tanto dentro de sus células
como en algunos alimentos que usted
ingiere
cuando el hígado metaboliza las purinas
se produce un producto de desecho
llamado ácido úrico
su cuerpo elimina este desecho a través
de los riñones que lo retiran de la
sangre
cuando el hígado produce demasiado ácido
úrico
o sus riñones no eliminan suficiente
ácido úrico de su cuerpo
se acumula un exceso de dicho ácido
úrico en su sangre dando como resultado
una afección llamada hiperuricemia las
bebidas con cafeína afectan la función
de eliminación de desechos de sus
riñones incrementando la producción de
orina lo que elimina de forma excesiva
el agua de su organismo provocando una
afección llamada deshidratación
y la deshidratación puede producir una
mayor concentración de ácido úrico en
los fluidos corporales
cuando la concentración de ácido úrico
es demasiado alta debido a cualquiera de
estas fuentes ya no se puede disolver
el exceso de ácido úrico empieza a
formar cristales articulares en forma de
agujas dentro de sus articulaciones con
mayor frecuencia en el dedo gordo del
pie la formación de los cristales de
ácido úrico conlleva a una respuesta
inflamatoria los glóbulos blancos del
sistema inmune atacan a los cristales de
ácido úrico provocando dolor e
inflamación de la articulación a esto se
le llama un ataque agudo de gota si no
es tratado los niveles elevados de ácido
úrico pueden dar lugar a depósitos
llenos de bultos de dicho ácido úrico
alrededor de la articulación llamados
tofos provocando dolor adicional y la
desfiguración de la articulación
el tratamiento para el ataque agudo de
gota incluye la colchicina para prevenir
o reducir la inflamación articular los
medicamentos antiinflamatorios no
esteroides para reducir el dolor y la
inflamación y los medicamentos
esteroides tal como la prednisona
el tratamiento para la gota crónica e
incluye los medicamentos que promueven
la expresión del ácido úrico y aquellos
medicamentos que inhiben la producción
de ácido úrico en su cuerpo
y los cambios en su estilo de vida para
prevenir la gota recurrente o crónica
incluyen reducir las carnes rojas y
mariscos de su dieta limitar el consumo
de alcohol con alto contenido de purinas
limitar el consumo de bebidas cafeinadas
hacer ejercicios de forma regular e
ingerir bastante agua